[Music]
hello everyone and welcome back to the
endgame class so as my name is Caleb
Denby and today I wanted to walk you
guys through some end games that magnus
carlsen has recently played following up
on the theme of the lecture from the
road mm tonight
these are end games from games between
Magnus Carlsen and his two closest
rivals in Fabiana Cara Juana and ding
Lauren I wanted to show some of these n
games where Magnus really out plays his
two rivals as I've said and shows how
you know dominance in every facet of the
game is important to keep that number
one spot
so starting off with we had an end game
between 9s and Fabi that I wanted to go
over of course this is not an openings
class so we're skipping through all of
this garbage and we ended up in this
position here which I'm I'm willing to
call kind of a sort of an end game
already so initial thoughts on this end
game are likely that it's it's going to
be pretty good for white because while
white isn't up upon Y it does have the
potential to make a passed pawn on the
e-file whereas black has a past
potential past pawn on the Aged file but
much more importantly the white rooks
are in better position at the start of
this endgame to sort of invade sort of
create very concrete threats compared to
the black rooks the black rooks simply
aren't in time to challenge both of
these files additionally in the Battle
of the minor pieces it's very much white
who is winning with the better Bishop
compared to the knight and the way you
can evaluate that kind of thing is in
end games that are Knights versus
bishops it is useful to look at the
bishop and say okay well if this bishops
kind of hemmed in by pawns on its own
color then it's not a good Bishop in the
night ship
better but that's not actually the the
way I like to think about it I think
much more relevant is whether or not the
night is good compared to whether or not
the bishop is good and the night is
going to be good if it has outposts even
in the endgame outposts are going to be
really really important not necessarily
as you know a huge you know attacker
like you might think of a knight on f5
in the middle game being an important
outpost but more so just so that the
knight has a square or it can keep an
eye on some pawns and not have to worry
about being harassed having to move
around if it gets kicked at a moment's
notice and if you look at this board
they're just really aren't any outposts
for this Knight there aren't any squares
it can feel safe on if it goes to e5 it
has to deal with the threat of capture
by the bishop it also has to deal with a
potential f4 break at some point if it
goes to c6 it's true that this is a safe
Square but so far back on the board like
c6 it's just not going to be very useful
back there and other than that I
struggle to find a single square on the
board that this Knight is is going to be
happy with so white definitely has a
distinct advantage here thanks to this
imbalance of the minor pieces and also
thanks to this imbalance of the rooks
white being slightly more active with
these rooks so let's see how Magnus
tries to convert this slight edge into
something more than a slight edge and
eventually a winning position so to
start off with what do you guys think
here wait to move try and find the best
move to push for a win
wait to move here guys I know you guys
are still filtering into the chat room
but try and find something here for
white to uh to try to win I'll give you
just a few moments as you all filter in
so just some more brief comments on the
position of course the way to kind of
push for a win is going to be to try to
find some way to force a rook onto the
seventh rank so that's kind of the
tactical idea we're looking for here
we're looking for some way to force our
way on to the seventh rank to create
significant problems for our opponent
all right I think people are still
coming into the chat room so I'm just
going to reveal this one the move of
course is the move rook to d4 this is
the best way to kind of build threats in
the position the reason for that being
is rook d4 makes a very concrete threat
of playing or exceeds d1 which would
just be simply winning a knight
and so this very much forces black's
hand to make some pretty tough decisions
here now in the game Fabi chose to play
the move Knight East 7 and of course 97
is being a little bit too friendly to
white the reason for that being the
movie Rexy 7 now comes on the board and
after rook c7 happens white very much
definitely has a almost winning
advantage if not winning already so a
better try for black here rather than 97
letting the rook into the seventh rank
is actually the the slightly less
intuitive move Knight b6 I did say that
you know c6 and potentially e5 are
really the only two squares for this
night but b6 does have its merits as
well the point being now we can at least
somewhat oops somewhat challenge these
rooks in the center with a move like
rook D to c8 here what the idea being
yes you got on the set seventh rank but
my Knight is guarding the second rooks
entry and I'm getting on the second
as well if you dare fight me like this
and if white thinks he can be clever and
take first well then the movie rook d7
is definitely going to come you be
putting a stop to those dreams for for
white so 96 a really interesting idea
the point being after X is 7 we don't
take on d4 but rather play this move or
a dc-8 and and try to get some counter
play
unfortunately Fabi missed this in the
game instead playing move 97 and of
course Magnus jumps at the opportunity
to put a rook on the seventh with rook
c7 now Knight a5 played in the game led
to Rick g4 there's pressure on g7
there's pressure on b7 and it's not so
easy to navigate the complications
there's really only one way of playing
here for for black to not lose the game
on the spot of course white has made a
very immediate threat of playing the
move efore and taking on g7 when black
made as well be checkmated because that
King is looking very very stuck in fact
probably is just checkmated so black has
to solve this issue somehow the only
real way to solve it is to play this
move h5 as is done in the game now this
rook comes into g6 but the situation is
slightly different move played in the
game by Fabi is rook e8 just to stop
this movie for it is kind of that bad
but now Magnus finds the best
continuation here which is to just
capture directly on f6 and now the black
king side has sort of exploded so you
very much wouldn't expect to see things
go this wrong for black this quickly
from that initial position or at least I
wouldn't maybe you see it all coming but
starting from here and and getting to
here seems like a bit of a stretch right
and so that goes to show you how even in
sort of innocuous-looking positions like
this
I guess innocuous is my new favorite
word it's said that a few times tonight
even in positions that that looked like
this
you can't just sort of casually go for
these kinds of end games from middle
game positions you know I think a lot of
players would take a look at this end
game say three versus three over here
two versus two over here I'm I'm
probably in time to to get to these open
files should be fine here right easy
drop but that's that's very much not the
case it's not the case for Fabiana
karamaneh and it's certainly not the
case for lower level players because
these positions are not so simple after
all and with just one or two Tempe you
could very much find yourself in this
situation from those starting positions
as Bobby did in this game now follow me
to his credit does a very good job of
trying to keep this game going comes up
at the move rookie six here and rookie
six is definitely asking white some
questions to solve with the move rook
takes f6 not yet being threatened but
being a potential idea to follow and
actually no it is just being threatened
what am I talking about
or takes f6 is a threat and Magnus does
unfortunately for Fabi find the correct
move which is e for just trying to evict
this Knight and get on to the g7 square
in the game rook takes e4 was fabi's
choice regaining one of them are
regaining the pun but now after rook g5
this is a fork and sort of everything is
hanging in the black position wreckage
for Czech was come up with by Fabi King
g1 rook e8 now still trying to hold it
all together
g3 g4 and rook takes f5 now and with
Rick takes f5 Magnus is saying okay you
know you've defended well enough I'm
ready to go into a rook head game and
I'm going to claim that I can win this
work end game so G takes f6 is more or
less forced by Fabi here and Rick takes
b7 just makes sense by Magnus picking up
the pawns and now your task is Fabiana
Cara Juana is trying to find a way to
get to some kind of position
that could you know once every 10 games
end up in in a draw here right so what
do you do with a black piece is to dry
it to try to draw a position like this
and what do you guys think and I'm now
realizing that my chat is frozen so
maybe you guys are answering my
questions all along and I just couldn't
see you you guys in fact we're answering
my questions I hate it when that happens
sometimes the chat just freezes
so jarda says the move h4 and in fact
this is the best try here and it follows
this kind of principle that we know in
end games where if you're on the
defending side the best thing you can
possibly do is try to trade pawns to
steer the game into a position that is
more easily drawn trading pawns is sort
of your best friend in these kinds of
positions because if you manage to get
all the puns off the board guess what
you're not losing that position because
there's no pawns left on the board so
that holds true here so definitely the
move H 4 is blacks best bet here and now
one potential idea is to just take on a
7 allow black to capture on g3 and say
you're gonna win this position with your
connected past pawns but this is
definitely not the easiest practical way
to to play so Magnus of course does not
go for this I'm not entirely certain if
this line is is even going to be winning
for white because the King is just so
out in the open rather than that Magnus
comes up with a good move rook f4 and
says yeah ok I'm willing to trade off
one set of rooks here to keep my king a
bit safer I'm even willing to let you
double my pawns just so long as you
don't take off all my pawns so Rick out
four is a great move by Magnus
practically rook takes up four G takes
up four played in the game and now we
have this this position so I'm gonna
skip through no I'm not gonna skip
through a few moves I'll ask you to look
from this position after rook a8 so if
you're playing with the white pieces
here
what is the winning tribe first of all
what do you expect your opponent Fabiana
karamaneh to be doing with those next
few moves and then what do you want to
be doing in response what is White's
idea against black blacks blacks plan
what can you come up with here
yeah unfortunately for black rookie to
just was not gonna get it done here if
you play rookie to Rick's a seven and
you might feel better about yourself but
your Kings on the back rank and these
pawns are gonna start rolling eventually
Rick a 4 B 4 a 3 or a 5 B 5 and the fact
is this Rick might look better on b2 but
with connected passed pawns this is just
always going to be a win for for white
so Rick a instead by by Fabi
so you guys have the start of the plan
and kind of the the generic idea of the
plan you know of course get the king in
the game start by winning this H pawn of
course though what is probably going to
be doing and while you're while you're
doing this
what's Bobby's idea
what's fabi's plan while you're busy
getting your King into the game so yeah
Bobby's gonna be doing a five a four so
that's what these end games are about
it's easy to come up with the principled
approach you know the principle
approaches get the King into the game
but then you do have to start actually
calculating actually thinking so with
the white pieces here try to see super
far ahead try to say okay King G to a5
King h3 a for King takes h4 a takes b3 a
takes b3 what's next it's pretty easy to
get this far in your head because this
is really the only logical way that the
game can kind of continue for either
side these are the moves that just make
the most sense so try to find from this
position in your games or positions like
this in your games you know what happens
next
try to think even further so how does
white go about winning that resulting
endgame that we see where White has the
two F pawns and the B pod Black has the
one F pawn what is sort of the winning
plan in that position what can we do to
try to win
after a four can't you just play b4 I
guess this is an idea to consider as
well
so you guys are saying you know go after
the f-pawn right which unfortunately is
a case of easier said than done right
because imagining this position a B 3 a
B 3 you play you know King G for going
after the F pawn you have to start
playing who is for your opponent as well
let's say this or it comes to a2 as some
people in the chat we're saying if you
just go directly King f5 you know black
might just take on f2 next thing you
know this F pawn is under a little bit
of pressure and things could could get a
little risky but you guys do have the
right general idea the specifics of it
turn out to be that you have to use kind
of some mating threats against the black
king to advance your agenda but you guys
do have the right idea in general here
so let's go ahead and put it on the
board now King G to a5 king h3 a floor
and yes the movie 4 is playable here and
the move before is actually just a good
move but it turns out it's it's
unnecessary to win the game so Magnus
allows a takes b3 and now rook a5 was
actually fabi's choice so Rick a5 was
his way of sort of saying yeah nice try
going after my f6 pawn but I'm Fabiana
karamaneh
I see this idea and I'm gonna try to
make it difficult on you at the very
very least so what's the winning plan
now what's the winning plan now
how do we ever cross this fifth-ranked
how do we do it
b4 b5 well like it's the play moves to
right so so b4 what's your opponent
doing what's your opponent doing
pushing the beep on ok sure but look
give me the specifics here give me the
specifics everybody how do you win this
game Marge beep on up the board what
does it do
how do what does it do kingi for firsts
okay black passes B for black moves the
rook B five black passes now you have
let B six rook B 5 and then black passes
King G for black passes I don't see it I
don't see it before rook a forward
rotation abhi the idea so b4 rook d5
we're staying on the fifth rank we're
not we're not being so friendly to you
as to allow King age five how are you
playing King g6
how are you playing King g6 I don't
understand them because beep on well
using the Robo gave me the moves gave me
the moves
give me the moves so far this seems to
be the prevailing theory I said black
passes b6 will put the rook here how do
you win how do you win this position f3
King g4 f 5f floor okay black passes how
do you win you just bring the King over
okay black passes how do you win
March the king over to the b-pawn I
remain slightly unconvinced by the March
the king over to the b-pawn plan
okay so Karolos has an idea to play f5
blocking the F file and then king h5 and
after it takes f5 king g6 so let's
calculate let's calculate first for just
a moment here so let's say you get what
you want
black passes as I promised you play the
move King h5 rook takes f5 King g6 are
you winning this position and how and
how
so the key point is we're sacrificing
the f5 pond
are you winning this position
well it's it's black to move everybody
it's black to move
Bashar says no Brooksie seven has been
has been said
Daniel says completely winning you guys
are not giving me the and how part work
takes up to rook f7 check King it
[Music]
you guys are almost there almost there
it's interesting to try to communicate
with the chat like this so yeah b7 rook
b2 rook b6 seems highly illegal but the
move rook c7 of course is going to be
the winning idea here the point being we
come to the c8 square next with check
and be a queen is unavoidable but you
have to see this far in order to win
this game and that's really what end
games are are all about is just pure
calculation because if you do go for
this kind of hodgepodge plan of just
coming all the way over to this side of
the board
rook could be won for example King c4
King d8 King see 5 okay maybe I was a
bit too friendly
okay here root be one for example if you
come all the way over to this side of
the board it's not so easy to it to win
this game right it's not so so easy
right this this rook now has to move and
things can can complicated rather rather
quickly and rather quickly for example
it's it's not so so clear what's what's
going on here not so so clear but if you
do see this idea of king g6 and then you
see the follow-up where if black dares
to capture the F pawn we can promote the
b-pawn and then you do see the winning
idea of course the line I didn't mention
if the search just comes back to b6 of
course this is just totally winning with
two pawns with two extra pawns to passed
pawns is rook h7 possible
I think h7 is possible here but I it's
less forcing it I mean it doesn't matter
I lost the line for a second hold on
this is actually how it happened in the
game with King edge five King g6 and
rook C's have been being played
Rick h7 I guess is fine Rick f7 check
would be transposing the some stuff
we've already seen although no real
reason to allow this well I guess this
isn't even isn't even a threat but yeah
Rick h7 I think wins just as well with
Rick h8 check to follow so that was sort
of the softball to start the class with
and it actually ate up quite a bit of
time so just some key notes on this Rick
end game here first of all from this
starting position that we took a look at
even though it does look rather tame
white is very seriously threatening just
kind of winning the game on the spot by
invading on the seventh rank as he did
so don't judge a book by it's cover in
this case because you can't end up in
quite a great deal of trouble from
starting positions that look as simple
as this one also notably Magnus's
technique when winning and fabi's
attempted drawing technique h4 is a
great idea
attempt to get closer to a draw and rook
F 4 is also a great keeping as many
pawns on the board as possible and from
there we did discover this winning idea
of sacrificing the F pawns in order to
get the King into G 6 in advance the
speed pawn the last little bit that we
needed of course by the way if black
dared to play move like King d8 and king
c8 well you're running into a little bit
of trouble with your with your F 6 upon
as well so that is that endgame I want
to move along now to another endgame
here we've got one between Magnus
Carlsen and ding Lauren in this position
I suppose will start I didn't kind of
speed through some moves there to start
with but let's take a look here at
what's going on for Magnus Carlsen so we
have another case of the bishop versus
the night and in this case we have any
isolated pawn on d5 and aya Salani as
they say and a very strange-looking sort
of fluid structure for white on the
Queen side in the center and once again
some reasonably active pieces for both
sides in this case no no chance this
time of a rook really getting to the
seventh rank immediately so a slightly
more balanced position I would say in
this case and so let's see what happened
the move Rick a5 came on the board and
so of course white isn't interested in
allowing the stroke to get super super
active so we just see the move Bishop d3
and the point of this move is that now
if you continue with a move like Rick be
to check I'm just gonna play Bishop c2
and without too much further ado I'm
going to play a move King b1 and king v2
and get you out of my business
of course if you're ok one I'm
responding with Bishop b1 and then king
b2 is coming with Tempest so not a huge
deal over here on the Queen side
actually for white although it does look
scary at first glance 97 was ding the
runs choice in the game and now King c1
gets played sort of voluntarily by
Magnus just key
this rook rook c5 played and now king b2
to keep an eye on these entry points
rook e8 now by ding Lauren keeps an eye
on this week eeep on we have rookie 195
and now the move b4 comes with tempo on
the rook now in this case ding Lauren
decided that it was in his best interest
to take off and he minor pieces
Magnus could have considered trying to
keep this bishop on the board but while
I said in the last game that the knight
looked bad because I had no squares this
Knight definitely has some squares
specifically this 'if I've Square to
start with is a very very great square
and if white ever wants to get rid of
this Knights he's gonna have to make
some very serious concessions and a move
like f4 and as soon as f4 comes on the
board
guess what this night has an even better
Square on e4 so because this Knight has
squares the bishop isn't really gonna be
much better in this case which is why we
see Magnus happy to just trade it off on
d3 so we do see this trade and network
b5 is the only move to keep the pawn
defended and King b3 is natural bring
the King up to support these queenside
pawns we have King to f8 rook a 1 now
pokes at a7 makes it come to a6 and now
I'd like you to try and find the winning
attempt the winning plan here for Magnus
Carlsen see if you can come up with what
he came up with here to try and win this
game it's a pretty nice idea did Anish
beat yan
not yet Ginga not yet I'm Eve yan won
the mini match here today and so they
will be moving to a 3rd mini match to
determine the series
so give me the full idea seeing someone
movers seeing someone movers give me the
full idea
yeah so everybody in the grandmother
wants to play the mover okay five but
explain why and give give a line give a
line
unfortunately King May 4 doesn't kick
the rook right and this works pretty
pretty stable pretty stable
so you guys are on very much the right
track you're getting a little bit
distracted buying this deep on it's not
actually all about the deep on but it is
very much about getting the King into
the game and you're very very much
correct about that
Rick k5 is a great great move here to
try and win this game so more or less
forces the move aruch takes and b5 you
don't really want to go for this
structure unfortunately this is just
kind of dooming you to an eventual rook
swinging around for example let's say
king c2 immediately maybe not maybe just
to move like g4 taking a minute of the
open space and this guy kind of has
nowhere to go and whoops the daisies all
your pawns are dying so rook takes a5 is
going to be the move B takes a five but
now unfortunately after the move Ricky
five it's not as easy to just sort of
win this pawn out of nowhere right it's
it's not the easiest thing in the world
if you do these uh these crazy things
like f4 well now all of a sudden this
this guy is going to be a little bit
weak right so you can't go totally hog
wild here and give up your age pawn for
the D pawn so this D pawn not the
easiest thing in the world to win also
note that even if you get your king up
to c5 okay well that was a bad move as
soon as you capture this guy I'm taking
on e3 right so this is not just like a
free pawn that you're winning so what is
the further winning idea after for
example King before King g7 as played in
the game of course you don't just go
after D pawn I'm sure you guys also
realize that you can go after this B
pond and a pawn as well but how do you
get there how do you get to b6 how do
you get to the promised land of b6 where
you can capture all these great pawns on
b7 and a six
how do you actually get there everybody
rook d4 then king c5 well maybe you're
being a bit too friendly a bit too
friendly Chesky rook d4 is giving away
the advantage in fact it's giving your
opponent the advantage you you aren't
really yet in time to get in here and
rookie to is it's kind of just cleaning
up your King sights
I'm not rook d4 not rook d4
so what's the problem with Kings c5 King
C fives the natural move but there's a
problem with it there's a problem
it's not all so easy it's not all so
easy
what's the problem with Kings c5 well
King c5 d4 why not king takes d4 ah
because the a pawn hangs that's right so
Kingston five the issue is in fact I'm
going to be the move d4 check ands
there's no way it can be six it's gonna
be good because whoops you're letting
your opponent make a queen
well almost you can try and hold on but
this is pretty desperate and King takes
here you're allowing or takes a five and
once again white is on the worst side of
a draw so King c5 doesn't work so what
is to be done about the move d4 check
how do you try to win so yeah you guys
now putting in the chat the move f4 and
I think this is the best try now
maybe black still could have held on to
things a bit by playing the move
wreckage five I think this is the best
resilient defense here if white tries to
continue it's sort of stubbornly with
moves like g4 we it takes and takes and
after rook a to we are for the moment
still preventing king c5 if white gets
ambitious in place king c5 directly now
still rook a - and King b6 and black has
a pawn you know your King got active but
but black has upon and that pawns not
going away
for example King e6 just solidifies here
and upon as a pond as they say so in the
game though Tingler n plays the move
rookie four and this is definitely the
move that permanently gives away the
advantage I think to white now king c5
as we were all thinking rook a for him
being a six rook d4 is now taking more
control of the center of course I want
to mention on this move we are not
interested in where takes d5 or King
takes d5 we want our King on the Queen
side so King e6 your tea for mr. comes
to a3 and now II for is the great follow
up by Magnus Carlsen while it's true
that isolated Queen pawns are kind of
seen as weaknesses in positions like
this where they're easy to attack Magnus
isn't afraid to
offer his epon which is also a weakness
for him especially because it's opening
up the center now that the black rook is
sort of misplaced to handle it so great
movie for by magnus rook b3 is a check
however we do not care so much
simply king c7 allowing Rick takes c3 if
our opponent dares because it turns out
these pawns are gonna be much more
valuable
oops hit Mike D takes c4 instead root
takes e4 check King f5 and now the key
move here for Magnus what do you guys
got every move is good but the key move
of course is rook before interfering
with this rook and now these pawns will
die the rook takes c3 check King takes
b7 rook C to g3
played in the game King g4 sorry rook
takes H - can you take h6 rook g4 sorry
King g4 and now I want to ask you guys
what you think the evaluation of this
position is and why and I will say as
with most onions this one is much much
trickier than you might expect much much
trickier than you might expect
why not Rick h3 after rook h4 I'm a
little lost a little lost in how the
rook ever ever went there draw zero zero
zero zero zero plus 50 plus 40 zero
point zero zero zero zero zero point oh
one by jarda okay so it's either a win
or a draw everybody agrees the blacks
not winning that's good at least we
agree on something
white winning
so you guys always do this where you
answer the first question but not the
second question so of course the
character of these these end games are
that black is eventually going to have
to sacrifice his entire rook for the a
pond that's just kind of what happens
here the question that remains is will
black be able to draw using the pawns on
the King side versus the rook and the
reason he sometimes can is because the
white king is so so far away that often
white has to sacrifice the rook back for
upon on the Kings side now evaluating
those positions is is rather difficult
and most of the time it just comes down
to to calculating calculating it out
however there is a really key point that
I want to introduce to you guys in this
specific endgame and that becomes very
very important now in the game the move
rook b3 was played by Magnus Carlsen
this is very much not the best try
trying to desperately hold on to this
guy rook a to was played in the game
King b6 by Magnus Carlsen and now this
is simply way way too slow in order to
try to win now pretty much every move
here draws for black you know g5 draws
f5 draws h5 draws g6 draws rook a one
probably draws although I don't think
you want to be doing that but in the
game unfortunately ding Lauren
disconnected and lost the game here
because of that disconnect losing on
time that's why we saw Magnus have a
little bit of fun in game 2 and just
throw the game back to ding in a you
know good sportsman like maneuver where
it leveled the score because ding is
likely just drawing this position very
easily so now let's give him the point
back however that's not the interesting
part the interesting part is what
happens if the move King to b5 is played
here so black to move what do you guys
think should be done here and I'll give
you a hint there is but one move that
holds the draw this position is in fact
a draw but there is
only one way to do it so points to the
person who can tell me the one way to
draw and how
okay five check and take the pun is
being suggested King takes g3 is being
suggested rook a 4 is being suggested
for white unfortunately that's not the
question
so of course your RK 2 is a bit of a
mistake right because the move rook rook
a4 is still playable
this is kind of the point of king b5 is
we're preserving this option to play the
movie okay for
age five rookie two is suggested alright
so in all of the chats infinite wisdom
none of the move suggested are drawing
of course you don't want to sacrifice
the rook so early you want to hold on to
your rook sort of as long as possible
here because now the white king can just
kind of get back in time you haven't
gained any time on the Kings side by
doing this so a better version of this
is the move rookie - which was suggested
or rook d2 they're kind of the same I
think even Rexy - is the same and the
point is after a six you are just in
time to come all the way back but as
there was one drawing move for black
earlier there is one winning move for
white here so we'll discuss that later
I'll discuss that later first find the
drawing move for black nobody has
suggested it yet literally zero people
unless I'm unless I'm mistaken scrolling
back up I don't think anyone has said it
yet g5 has been suggested King takes g3
has been suggested and we do have our
first correct answer and that answer is
the move f5 which is rather
counterintuitive in fact very
counterintuitive I would I would dare
say you know you would think that you
know f5 isn't really the move that helps
you advance the pawns trying to make a
queen but the fact of the matter is if
you do try this very direct approach of
just getting the rook in front of the
pawn before it's too late you are going
to be hit with a bit of a shell shocker
here and move f5 check this is the one
winning move for white in this position
and then the fact of the matter is if
King takes g3 King a6 chief g 6f 6 age
five King G King b7 other
it's king takes eight these positions
are just always going to be winning from
white and the reason is even if you
start pushing this guy guess what you're
too slow you're just a little a little
bit too slow and with one pawn still on
the board white is almost always going
to be winning these positions unless the
black pawn is very very far advanced to
begin with so this is the key winning
idea is this f5 check and so in fact
after King takes g3 there is still I
believe just one winning move here and
once again well actually maybe it's
important you start with a6 which does
force this rook now to come back a seven
Rick d8 and now of course the move f5 is
absolutely critical with the same idea
as before
f5 locking this pawn on a square where
it's safe cutting off this black King
from reaching it and now white is simply
winning this position so really
important idea to keep in mind so after
King b5 only move that draws f5 by black
this is enough to hold the position but
I do believe that this move is actually
forced it's a really important idea to
keep in mind and so what's the
difference here well let's take a look
at it a six Ricky - a seven ok Apes King
anywhere c6 will say rook 8 king b7 or
it takes a 7 check King takes a 7 now
King takes g3 and wait a second King b6
h5 King c5h 4 as soon as the King steps
over this square hold on a second this
pawn dies and if it doesn't we push this
guy all the way down to h2 rook b1 just
in time to stop and believe it or not
here
the black king and the remaining black
pawns are actually just enough to tie
down all of the remaining white pieces
here g6 is the only move to hold the
draw in this
position and believe it or not this rook
being confined to the first drink this
King is confined to defending this F
pawn and there's simply no way to win
this position for white if you ever play
this move I take here and draw in this
manner
if you pass I play King f3 very
important to keep an eye on this pawn
still if you pass and go here I have to
move King g2 rook b1 now very important
I don't capture sorry wait what am I
saying
very important I don't play the move h1
Queen and lose this resulting king upon
endgame but I can repeat with the move
King g3 and this is somehow just enough
to hold the draw for black in a very
strange sort of position where white is
just too tied down to to make any
progress really impressive stuff do I
think ding would have found it I have no
idea it's a rapid game I do think at
some point f5 is probably an intuitive
move for these guys it may not be
intuitive for you and me but I think
they've seen enough of these end games
to understand that it's important to
kind of lock down this F pawn before
it's too late
regardless though Magnus did not play
the move King b5 and so in the final
position where ding did disconnect and
flag it was a little bit more clear-cut
that the position was just drawn and so
Magnus probably felt justified you know
going for this Queen takes d2 just
throwing the game and move to and
feeling good about it so that is a
really nice end game that I wanted to
show off to you guys and then I don't
know how this is but this always seems
to happen probably because I asked you
guys more questions in the end game plus
but we made it through like 4 full games
on the road to 2000 and we're only
getting the two end games in the end
game class I don't know how this happens
do grandmasters calculate that long or
they are already prepared so in your
standard over the board time control
chess when they have you know like 45
minutes left on their clock they hit
move 60 they have so much time left to
think that's when you can expect them to
actually calculate all of this out from
the move King b5 but in rapid games
obviously they're not soo
they're not calculating that far some of
its just intuition that they've
developed over the years from studying
these end games some of it is some some
principles that they've kind of either
consciously or unconsciously developed
but there's no substitute for the
calculation that you'll see when they do
have the time to do it I think that just
about does it for our end game class
here tonight if you're watching live be
sure to head over to the twitch channel
where we will be continuing with analyze
your games if you're watching the video
that is it for tonight
thank you guys so much for joining me
until next time my name is caleb ben b
thank you for watching
[Music]
[Applause]
you
[Music]